do you think
is there an argument to be made for and
against
banks so his arguments be made for
everything a permanent ban seems to be
an overreaction to me
he's the president of the united states
it also rearranges the power like
whether you like him or hate him love
him hate him
he was the president we've elevated
twitter is now more powerful than the
president
it's like do you want that to be
long-term the salute the reality like
now jack at twitter
is more powerful than the president of
the united states is that a good
paradigm going forward i don't know
i'm not listen maybe give him a little
time out for a few days
yeah i think it timeout a little
spanking yeah certainly
but i don't know if a permanent ban
across the board on every social media i
mean they banned them on grindr i mean
this is how hilarious it is right
i mean across the board on everything i
don't think he could get an airbnb now
neither can i but like
i don't think he can do anything again i
just i look back and there's so many
people i'm very smart intelligent
friends that go yeah but who cares yeah
but he's bad
yeah but blah blah blah yeah but i don't
like melodianopolis yeah but blah blah
blah blah
and i'm like you have such faith you
have such
faith that it's always going to be the
people you dislike that are banned
it's always going to be the p it's never
going to be you man you have so much
faith in the government you have so much
faith in tech oligarchs you've never met
you have so much face faith in the
security state
that they're going to always make the
right decisions and they're not going to
penalize
people that shouldn't be penalized to me
i'm like
wow i've never had that much faith in
any human being ever including myself
i wouldn't want that power i would start
de-platforming people that i hate
i would platform my aunt you know what i
mean i would de-platform everyone i know
i mean so that it's like it's it's such
a insane power to give somebody like who
gets heard
who gets to speak yeah i'm worried about
the effect it has on people like you
actually i agree of being like
everybody's
a little more nervous in
what they say correct and that that's a
big problem yes because then you're just
like long-term unmasked like we're
talking about it has an effect where
people just become
more bland yeah self-censorship
anxiety all of these things go into we
try to fight it but i try to fight it i
think i think i gotta still do what
makes me laugh and what makes me laugh
is often [ __ ] up
and it's often you know it's not always
[ __ ] up in a way that you know it's
gonna get me thrown off something but
like
i think pushing certain buttons is funny
to me so i gotta keep doing that
you